I'm sure everyone's why this is the most
enraging
enraging video so zelinski shows up
dressed like [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know I under the whole I'm not gonna
wear a [ __ ] suit and tie thing
you could play that off for two weeks
when an invasion starts right but I'll
tell you this when Winston Churchill
visited the White House he didn't show
up in Bermuda shorts in a Hawaiian shirt
like he wanted to he showed up in a
[ __ ] suit
so the fact that they just have zero
respect and they flew a foreign flag in
our Congress which is what the [ __ ] and
did you see they're they're trying to
shame all there's a list of like seven
eight people that didn't that didn't
stand or clap for zelinski and they're
trying to shame them and be like why
didn't you guys clap
uh Matt Gates was one of them I forget
the full list I know it was but I was
like these are literally the only people
I vote for now honestly the only people
because why what why anybody else bro uh
they approved another 1.8 billion in our
spending package
for them because that's important
uh and then zelinski showed up and
couldn't be bothered to wear a tie
because he's at War apparently and
um let's see what he said but he's here
he's not getting shelled right now right
I can't even say what I want to say
even on Rumble
when I was in Batman yesterday our Our
Heroes
gave me
deflect
the battle sack the flag of those who
defend Ukraine Europe and the world at
the cost of their lives they asked me to
bring this flag to you to the yeah cool
do me a favor turn the heater off turn
the radio down and I'm gonna put my
headphones in just get me tell me when
we're there okay thanks
how's that
U.S Congress to members of the House of
Representatives and Senators whose
decisions can save millions of people
so not our own though not if you live in
a Border Town those people don't get
help
because they're not Ukrainian enough
let these decisions be taken let this
flag stay with you lettuce and gentlemen
this flag is a symbol of our victory in
this war
Yeah by Russians so oh no they got a
graphic designer on Fiverr yeah who was
probably rushing
because you're right though it is
probably what happened right they went
to Fiverr you're 100
it'll be a little extra because it's two
colors
kids quickly
please make sure you have black sun in
it
put a watermark so no one steals thank
you today in the United States cronkers
I want to announce the new Ukrainian nft
they are unite don't even put that out
into the universe because they'll do it
we're releasing the ghost of Kiev first
I love how our oppression always turns
into horse that's all it is it's easier
the blue it stands for freedom and the
yellow for peace
my best
here's what we think about you Ukraine
suck our dick hey team put you know what
Putin never asked me for money I'll tell
you that
no Putin just wants to kill me but at
least he's open about it hear me out he
says that [ __ ] to my face I floated
something on Twitter today merch tell me
what you think
since we're giving him so much money
right of passage for every American that
wants to go to Ukraine they go for free
like Israel Go for free we go hang out
and they provide sex trafficked
Ukrainian horse that sounds great okay
can I can I add another chip to that
Annie oh fine they could look like
suicide girls
all right well first of all let me add
two chips to the auntie
I'm
I'm saying dude we should be like
[ __ ] Israelis and Palestine [ __ ]
just walking in and taking their houses
when they go and walk their [ __ ] dog
and [ __ ] I like that I literally should
own that [ __ ] country bro Marsh we
move our listen ROTC media we move it to
Ukraine new headquarters we just bully
another radio station take it over boom
headquartered in Ukraine as long as we
we'd have to be Pro NATO though
okay hey now we're talking okay that's
good that's good let's go
let's do it and then we can and then
we'll just turn it into the um we'll
just turn it into like the typical uh
you know like uh like we'll be like
Eastern Europe's uh Kino Casino you know
what I mean we could be like oh man he's
like Long Live Russia for five million
Rubles let's go
right yeah but but but hold on hold on
but if we're gonna be that then we're
just gonna eventually be gone and be
Russia again
that's true I did Ukraine America
and the entire free world
thank you
here you go
stand for the Ukrainian flag you pieces
of [ __ ] no because this is what matters
no
you've got life on your flag
did you see that did you see Mitch
McConnell's the most important thing to
Republicans
is is Ukraine did you see that
no oh well no I he did oh yeah that's
right he did say that yesterday yep
yesterday this is the most important
thing and he's like to all Republicans
and then there's like some Republicans
that are going they're doing the Jonah
Hill meme where they're like Matt Gates
you know who else never talks about
Ukraine our governor
good point notice that he's the the word
Ukraine has never come out of his mouth
thank you I will now sell this on eBay
[ __ ] looks like it was [ __ ] it's this
is I don't want your [ __ ] cheap
polyester flag zielinski's like [ __ ]
Dan housing like yes now I will sell
this for many Monies
as far as We Know
I think that I think the McConnell Clips
in here so oh no one's ever addressed
the United States
all he wants is money from people all
the time and everybody's starting to be
sick of him and he's just like Dan
housing every once in a while he's just
here hello not like Jesus Christ he's
back I need another uh 50 million
dollars Cruise
God damn it man he starts just ambushing
other Senators while they're eating with
a camera like yeah ask him to take their
watches off and stuff how much is that
watch how much is that watch okay I
would like it please
um
so we're doing the giving a flag like we
give to the family of a Dead Soldier to
this guy
cool cool that's cool shirt before but
they love him much more than they love
you welcome to Dr Carlson site remember
when Sam bankman trade showed up in
Washington wearing a t-shirt and
spouting nonsense this is so awkward I
know hold on guys you're right I never
looked at okay
ignore what Tucker sank for a second and
just look at look at Nancy Pelosi this
is a great watch okay as far as we know
no one's ever addressed the United
States Congress in a sweatshirt before
but they love him
did you see that she went to give it to
him he went to grab it but she said no
no we need to take a photo we need to
take a photo watch watch look at her no
no one's ever addressed the United
States Congress in a sweatshirt photo
butt okay we'll take a much more hold on
come over we'll take a photo come here
Carlson remember when Sam bankman freed
showed up in Washington wearing a
t-shirt and spouting nonsense
what was that
my hero the media the Congress the White
House they all love this weird little
guy called Sam bankman free do you
remember
that
somehow we were reminded of it today
when the president of Ukraine arrived at
the White House dressed like the manager
of a strip club and started to demand
money
I love him man
Marsh was he dressed like you
no a strip club managers dressed nice
they wear suits you know how they dress
in the Ukraine Royce strip club man even
in a shitty Club the manager was a suit
you've never been to the shitty titty
at least a dress shirt right okay dress
shirt at least I will give you that yes
button up a button up a button up a
button up okay fair enough
amazingly no one threw him out and said
they did whatever he wanted American
taxpayers declared Joe Biden will
continue to give zelenski whatever he
demands for quote as long as it takes
telling me Biden ever specified what it
is as long as it takes to do what
push the Russian army back to
pre-invasion borders
sounds reasonable that's what most
Americans likely assume those who are
still paying attention but that is not
what zielinski means and it is not what
he is asking for
zielinski is demanding regime change in
Russia just like in Iraq and Libyan a
long list of other failed States except
this time in the heart of the Eurasian
land mass next door to the entire
civilized world
that's what zielinski has called for
repeatedly in every dollar we sent to
him goes toward that end
at this point it only doesn't make a
third of it does the rest of it goes to
line the pockets of his friends and buy
him another house in Pismo Beach
no that's not true Bahamas Bahamas fair
enough the Bahamas yeah hey I know a
mansion that's up for sale
down there
yeah that's cheap too yeah
it's covered with nerd come though so
you got to get that clean out of the
couches a bunch of nerd come
from achieving it so what happens which
just smells like Mountain Dew Baja Blast
and Cheetos
I think what wins
what is the ensuing chaos look like
thought about that no who's going to
secure the world's largest nuclear
Arsenal once we help zelenski they get
him outside the door and the CIA
operator comes up and shuts him off just
pushes the button on the back of his
neck
so yeah I'll tell you who's gonna get
who's gonna get the nukes like chechnya
is going to get her the [ __ ] nukes in
Russia that's gonna happen and then
we're gonna have a bigger problem
Russian government who replaces Putin
strangely those topics first off I was
told by Mark Levin it's pronounced Putin
Putin did not come up today
because that wasn't the point the point
of today's visit to Washington was not
he's a little man huh
I mean I don't know why you always have
to bring it up not you Virgie you make
the world more stable or make wise
decisions much less to help just because
you guys dress alike doesn't [ __ ]
mean that you know that you're the same
guy of America that's always yeah we do
the point was to Fergie in New York was
dressed like a goddamn orphan like he
was wearing like is that why you asked
me for advice about gin I did because I
honestly thought that you were an orphan
I was gonna hire him to sweep my chimney
fallen over the Ukrainian strip club
manager and hand him billions more
dollars from our own crumbling economy
it is hard in fact it may be impossible
to imagine a more humiliating scenario
for the greatest country on Earth
and we would love to blame Joe Biden for
it but we can't really not entirely at
least this was bipartisan masochism
the unit party is Alive and Well despite
the best efforts of Voters including
last month and if you doubt that it's
alive and well here's a picture of
zelenski look at him
is he flexing he is he's absolutely
flexing he's doing his War thing
he looks like an [ __ ] he doesn't look
like anyone anyone that was doing that
in a photo would be like bro you look
like an [ __ ] put your arms down you
don't have lats the only reason big
actual like bodybuilders arms are out
like that is because their lats are
literally holding their arms up right
what are you doing your arms are tired
if I were to hold my arms out like this
I'd get tired after a while
that he had taken with a group of
elderly Republican senators in Kiev back
in May
they stand grinning next to him in their
orthopedic shoes seven
he's just I mean he's a better comedian
now than comedians yeah people are
saying in the chat that you're saying
Tucker's funnier than Gutfeld
they stand grinning next to him in their
orthopedic shoes 70 year old Susan
Collins John barrasso John cornyn led by
their 80 year old ringleader Mitch
McConnell 44 year old zielinski poses
between them in a skin-tight polo shirt
flexing like a weightlifter and trying
to look ferocious
he was trying to look ferocious it's
brutal man look and we gave you all this
money we are gonna get our money's worth
making fun of you that's for [ __ ]
sure they seem awestruck he looks like a
house Castro showed up in New York
wearing battle fatigues
leadership class tittered more loudly in
Delight they love a man in uniform what
a hunk
bro I think he said I think he's just
he's like I need I think Tucker needs
his Christmas Vacation more than anybody
yeah he's [ __ ] angry [ __ ] raging
bro this looks like a bar mitzvah boy
posing with his grandparents
little shmuel he's 13.
he's a man now ma mom I want to go give
me the Planet Fitness I want to work out
a little bit
so strong and decisive
look at the expression it's by my
Mitzvah I shouldn't have to wear a shirt
and a tie if I don't want to
McConnell's face you can almost hear
this did they have to take the picture
right after they gave him his bar
mitzvah money yeah they did they did
he's happy because he just got it it was
just the most expensive Apartments ever
it was 140 billion dollar [ __ ]
apartments for money
a rational person assessing the issues
ever would have predicted this much time
for my annual by mitzvah
if you were an annual apartment he's
just getting one every year now
Republican office holder and solenski
came we're so pissed off because he also
has an annual an annual prison
how many circumcisions can one man have
it is basically just a nub at this point
it looks like how do you say Harvey
Weinstein's penis
you think they would just take pieces of
their foreskin but no they just take it
each every year now it looks like when
your rude neighbor cuts a tree down but
doesn't get the stump removed
that stuff JJ was watching
it's why I always come in peace
now we know why he says it you're right
his dick looks like an HOA violation
Jesus Christ naturally
[ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ] you suck our
dicks that's why that's why he needs all
this money is to pay the HOA fines
[Laughter]
I could I did not cut to my grass in
front of my
weeks okay you guys helped me out
they see in my trash cans from the road
we don't respect you you piece of [ __ ]
they say if I don't uproot my penis soon
they will find me find me more okay guys
this is really serious it's a real
serious it's a real serious war going on
versus the [ __ ] stump Mercer stump
thing killed me [ __ ]
huh
okay come on guys this is serious stuff
guys come on man we're a war
all right oh [ __ ] get back to fighting
them over there so we don't have to
fight him over here
maybe you would well [ __ ] can we go to
Africa then
[Laughter]
God I wish spicy spicy for a moment ask
him about his current and ongoing war
against Christianity in Ukraine
especially if you were say Mitch
McConnell or John cornyn and a lot of
your own voters go to church on Sunday
they might care about that issue
but McConnell and cornyn didn't mention
that they didn't say a word you will not
hear a word on television tonight about
the fact that zielinski has banned an
entire ancient Christian denomination in
Ukraine and then seized churches and
then thrown priests into jail
yes but guess what free Papa John
the wings are not that good but the
pizza is pretty good the garlic butter
sauce is delicious
[Music]
they make a giant cookie yeah you can
eat as well can you imagine it shows up
to ask for 141 billion dollars and he
just shows up with like three pizzas for
all of Congress that's it
you know what the best part is he showed
up he has to throw that money and then
everyone else still paid for all this
stuff too oh God you're right that's a
good point you just sat around sorry I
left my wallet in my other uh olive
green pair of pants
and I have Benny
I left it in my other fleece vest and
you know how long it took him to find it
because all his pants were the cargo
variety so there's a lot of pockets oh
sorry I left my credit cards in my suit
and then he leaves and then I go wait a
minute I've never seen him wear a seat
he doesn't have a suit actually did you
see the picture of zielinski with Trump
yes yes versus the the recent pictures
you mean you mean [ __ ] you mean beta
beta zielinski to trying to be Alpha One
yes the woman's dressed like Tony
Montana yeah
looks like an [ __ ] he does he looks
like a he looks like a criminal even in
a three-piece suit hey you know what
they say the man posted it and show it
the man the man makes the man makes the
suit Marsh
uh let's see here showing show like Show
links oh my God yeah yeah I've seen this
oh this is good hold on let me pull it
up
um it's just I mean the caption is
cringe Boomer [ __ ] but the picture
itself is just oh
and look at the body language is so
different too Trump's like I don't even
need to be here frankly this is stupid
I'm tired it's just a long flight you
could barely matters frankly
did you see the one with [ __ ] Biden
touching his butt that one's a funny one
well you know again I think the theory
is that I all think he's a little boy
thank you Mitch McConnell apparently
hasn't left his office since the mid 80s
anti-christian despotism is what most
Republicans are true occasionally
tough they're just begging for it watch
McConnell explain
providing assistance foreign to defeat
the Russians that's the number one
priority for the United States right now
according to most Republicans that's
really not the Border
not people dying of Fentanyl
you can ask yeah can I ask a question
then Mitch cocaine Mitch
how come none of you ran on that if it
matters so much to us
why did none of you just run on the
midterms on the Ukraine war you guys ran
on inflation you [ __ ] ran on the
economy you ran on the border you
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] so
if it really is the number one issue to
real Republicans out there why didn't
you run on that why didn't you bravely
stand out and say we if we don't [ __ ]
win in the midterms uh we're never gonna
defeat Russia with the Ukraine because
we you would have lost even more seats
because we don't care about it we're
going broke the stock market is in a
free fall right now yeah dude I logged
in and looked at my stocks today and I
almost had a [ __ ] heart attack
my portfolio is down a lot of money
we don't care about Ukraine bro no
you're right retirement funds I mean
this is this is nobody that's what bro I
can't imagine
what people's return like my portfolio
is down I'm not even kidding you because
I I just held on to the stocks and then
it crashed right after Biden and I'm
like I'm not gonna sell them at a loss
like I'm down like over 60 and that's
just me like that's my small portfolio I
can't [ __ ] imagine the nightmare
right now that somebody who had a giant
retirement plan that was like well well
I retire in 2021
oof
for how we see the challenges
confronting the country at the moment
and two other Senators stand behind him
nodding like it's true yep defeating
Putin is quote the number one priority
among Republicans says Mitch McConnell
who leads I don't want to this the
problem is that you know like you said
later like you were said yesterday merch
on the [ __ ] amazing local show that
everyone signed up for
um
I don't care anymore there's there's
there's no the only elections that
matter in our local ones in my opinion
you know take care of your state take
care of your city take care of your town
because Federal elections don't [ __ ]
matter any every every Republican there
except for six of them
is fine with this they they this is the
most important thing in the world
you know while at the same time we have
a was it 10 000 people a day just coming
in through El Paso
13
000 that they caught
yes yeah correct
number one but for our own economy or
our own Children's Schools or for that
matter before the more than 2 000 young
people killed last year by Fentanyl and
Mitch McConnell's quote home state of
Kentucky
punishing Vladimir Putin for putting
Donald Trump in office is more important
than all of that
says Mitch McConnell Ukraine's borders
matter ours don't matter
you may have suspected they thought that
oh but at this point they're just coming
out and saying this right in your face
and of course the White House agrees
completely watch Mitch McConnell
announced today that you'll be paying
for ever more advanced weapon systems to
be sent to Ukraine whether you like it
or not
we're in a continuous transition
Ukraine's ability to defend itself
particularly air defense and that's why
we're going to be providing Ukraine with
patriotism you come and ask for money
and you camp and look man what are you
Temple
you can't put a suit on or go to the
[ __ ] white no not even because
Tim Poole wasn't asking for 140 billion
dollars
no exactly he's just going to meet Trump
I think if you're going to ask for money
you should at least like I mean Jesus
Christ if you're trying to get like a
real giant like a big business loan
right right and you're going into JP
Morgan
wear a [ __ ] suit
right put forward unless you're [ __ ]
Michael Berry you know what I mean like
unless your name precedes you unless
you're a goddamn Legend you don't you
you wear a suit mm-hmm
and uh in his defense and speaking from
experience it is kind of hard to find a
suit that small buy with a hundred
billion dollars Virgie
you know I mean I just turned it to
Kevin you Kevin Brennan again
Club
and Virgie just buy a suit just get just
borrow one of Jeff Dunham's puppet suits
there you go problem solved yeah and I'm
sorry but it's not that hard for people
your size to wear suits I've seen Nick
Fuentes
just go in the boys section Jesus Christ
what do you think what do you think
people get communion suits yeah
seriously
forces to be able to accurately use it
he's reading his little script maybe it
was written by the defense contractors
that just hosted an event because
Washington for the Ukrainian Ambassador
literally they put their logos on the
invitation just in case there was any
question about what's going on here so
this is a big change from what we had
say last month but you wouldn't know
that from the media coverage of it your
average reporter in Washington like
zielinski a lot more than he likes you
so nobody asked about it but this is a
major policy change it was just a few
months ago that a senior U.S defense
official said and we're quoting there is
no discussion about putting a patriot
battery in Ukraine in order to do that
you would have to put U.S troops with it
to operate
in other words you would have to fight a
hot war against Russia that have not
been approved do they not can't they
can't we just go drop off a patriot
missile thing pop in a little VHS tape
and it's like hey my name's John Donegan
and I work at Raytheon and today we're
going to be teaching you how to operate
the Patriot missile system like a Cheesy
old 90s like Taco Bell training video
you might remember me for such films as
point this and towards enemy and
Bazookas how do they work
that's in you
I was also a producer on the moon
landing video but we won't get into that
it's true
don't we tolerate him the demands become
bigger you know Tucker the other day he
slipped something in he goes after three
times with a JFK thing is yeah we this
is the same country that supposedly
landed on the moon I'm like supposedly
what are you saying
case you missed it here's part of what
he said just a moment ago
my name Chanel my name yo I can't
understand your device because it's
gonna take them seriously
Joke Man everything's dude I keep
pointing this out the more we got these
characters introduced and it's like it's
just silly dude like the names remember
like the names like of people like
suspects now they're like all goof joke
names and now we have this guy like give
me 100 billion dollars I mean it sounds
like insult the [ __ ] the Triumph the
insult comic duck
I have come to this building in New York
to ask for more money
no no no no that's a Nancy Pelosi doll
that makes no sense oh fair enough fair
enough which one was the smart Gremlin
he was my favorite
financial's assistant is also critically
important and I would like to thank you
thank you very much thank you for both
Financial people packages you have
already provided us okay you're welcome
we're done now
unfortunately is not enough It's never
enough oh okay give me more your [ __ ]
sucker I see
with financial packages such a silly way
to say [ __ ] a hundred billion dollars
isn't it yeah I would like to end this
speech with a quote from your late great
Britney Spears Give me give me more give
me more give me give me more
[Laughter]
thank you for your time thank you we are
now going to get to work [ __ ]
and the ones you may be willing to
decide on your money is not charity
boy it sure feels like it because I'm
getting nothing in return absolutely
nothing and I have no say in it actually
no you're right it's not charity because
I have no say in giving it to you it's
really just you know charity under the
with Charity under the banner of the
government putting a gun to my head oh
okay I also need 250 million dollars
because I have to bail out a friend of
mine today from jail
and I'm going to need that cash today
you know it's sunny somebody pointed out
that this is for the Nerds but somebody
pointed out that he sounds like uh
he sounds like a Dalek from Doctor Who's
saying exterminate hold on
here you go impossible
[Music]
Jesus [ __ ] Christ he really does
donate donate
donate
it's an investment in the global
security and democracy
Global Security
that is not an investment Global
Security doesn't affect me
Global Security would be maybe our
border
Mexico is part of the globe can we stop
them from coming here we gotta protect
their their border first
we'll get to our border dude at some
point remember Royce we couldn't afford
the wall it was going to cost like three
billion dollars where are we gonna get
that kind of money
did you [ __ ] imagine if you handed a
homeless dude five dollars and he goes
this is not Kennedy you though for me it
is investment for your safety did you
see
did you see Medicare is not is is not
fun is underfunded by a 1.7 billion
dollars and we can't find the money I'm
being serious for like old people
Medicare is underfunded by 1.7 billion
dollars but we don't have it on us
we just don't have it weird
your money is not charity feels like it
it's an investment in the global
security and democracy also we're
investing in globalism sounds great see
that we handle in the most responsible
way
hey Flat Earth reality there's no Globe
I hear you about but here's the thing
don't focus on the shape regardless of
whatever shape you think the planet is
it's on a map and we're being [ __ ]
okay you're focusing on the wrong part
of this can you can fight earthers and
globetards get together and agree
regardless of what shape the planet is
this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
foreign
so the leader of a foreign government
dressed in a sweatshirt Waltz is into
the United States Congress
and starts demanding money and then as
the Gauls tell the people sitting there
who are giving him tens of billions of
dollars more of your money that is not
charity it's an investment really what
are the Returns on that
and by the way what's the point okay you
know what else was an investment FTX
that what is the goal here what's the
justification for it do we have a
historic debit to Ukraine that sounds
trendy and cool oh yeah you should check
out FDX just filter the search from
anything before 2022. do we have a
historic animosity with a non-soviet
Russia no no
how do we win here what's in it for us
isn't this our country and where do you
get off talking to us like that do we
hate ourselves so much yes
that we're a country full of only fans
girls we have that much low self-esteem
that's what we are that's our number one
export now we bend over and we present
our [ __ ] like baboons and let
everybody [ __ ] us while they just invade
our country and we're supposed to not
say anything because you're a Nazi a
bigot or you're just being solitary
confinement
do we have so little respect for the
United States of America that will put
up with that that will applaud it thank
you sir may I have another except for
six people
yes
what's wrong with us what's wrong with
our leaders
and where's this going subscribe to the
Fox news thank you uh I'll tell you
where it's going to World War III and
it's going to be fun it's going to be a
fun one guys I'm looking forward to it
hey guess what
major Toms might get his wish maybe not
in the way he expected it but I used to
get sucks because the third one's Never
As Good I mean most most trilogies Peak
with the second movies you know you
don't want to watch World War III rise
of the Machines nah this one's gonna
suck I World War III Coda oh God or
three salvation